I'm about to go to art school what I do
and I like at that time actually it was
also a professional video gamer I was
playing Street Fighter oh [ __ ] beta
testing counter-strike for valve this is
like 96 hmm yeah I was beta test
instance like 98 with them and then this
is when cows strike was like we could do
like bunnyhopping yeah yeah yeah and
then I was playing Cal and and then you
know I had a bunch of clans and and I
was trying to make money I was starting
to do that and I made money from that
and giving that to my parents when I
found out then we kicked our dad out of
the house my parents split up mmm and it
was a crazy time people go through this
you know this is a life thing right yeah
yeah yeah a life experience and then I
was like [ __ ] I got a really hustle you
know so I was doing the tournament's and
then I was like dang I got you're doing
video games like instead of going to get
a regular job you're like I gotta play
video games harder the time when video
games did not pay well no at that time
there's no eSports like there's no
eSports I was following professional
eSports player at that time yeah I mean
that'll file like a hundred people in
that community I know and this was 2000
like this was a 4-3 something yeah this
is like mm mm - mm yeah yeah no playing
games it's 98 but 96 well ever since I
was like five years old Nintendo but
like Street Fighter competitively since
98 99 yeah and then I had a bunch of
college books and I was like oh and that
time they had half calm which I don't
know if you guys were all back half calm
yeah which was owned by eBay yeah they
had eBay and Amazon was like losing
money at that time
it's half.com still around no yeah dang
you know I I think if I I had a lot of
opportunities and and revenue challenge
like it's you can call them but I went
on half calm and I had like you know you
have your like general studies whatever
they call him yeah at Santa Monica and
and and there was even a local bookstore
there in Santa as near SMC that like I
would buy books online and I do like
two-way trading in a way right yeah and
I buy them and I sell them for like
obviously as a profit which I buy for 50
I by itself or 65 whatever and I started
doing then online I was selling it
and then next thing I know like [ __ ]
what else I've found around the house to
sell that's hot in the eBay - yeah yeah
we talked about that yeah and I was like
[ __ ] like at that time I had a
girlfriend and her sister for some
reason had thousands of prenatal
vitamins that weren't expired and and
then she had like porcelain dolls and
things like that I sold all those things
I just listed them on the eBay wherever
I could I put them on so my my use books
like whatever is around the house yeah
put those online and then you know I was
like [ __ ] you know I'm starting to like
make some money and give my parents you
know some money from that and then at
that same time like I still need to make
some money and then I ended up applying
for my first and only corporate job
which I worked at Blockbuster Video yeah
yeah and then it was the blockbuster on
Lake Avenue
in Pasadena and I remember that like so
I had my my polo that I wore every day
and and then I worked only for six
months and I mean it was a good
experience and basically I worked there
became the number-one salesperson that
the Pirates Caribbean DVD okay Jose
heard this story many times but David I
think you know the whole story yeah so a
good story - thank you
and so I became the number one sales
person just as a cashier you know I
don't have you ever worked at any like
corporate retail yeah Men's Warehouse
Macy's do they make you go through like
a ten step checkout process if you work
the POS we're like yeah well we yeah we
had a mono ten step but we had a whole
checkout thing before we yeah like oh
hey how you doing it find everything
okay yeah yeah so I had to do that right
but I am always selling price Caribbean
DVD and I was they said I was the number
one seller in SoCal what the [ __ ] we're
selling so many yeah you know because
almost every customer and get them to
subscribe or whatever you call that and
buy it or yeah or sell like a
subscription car whatever they were
selling at that time they would never
get Commission and then at the same time
when I first started I had to clean the
bathroom for like two weeks
and and I was like I signed them for a
cashier job yeah not a janitorial you
know yeah and I told myself that okay
number one if if I had a salesperson or
have had people that worked hard
I would compensate them properly yeah
you should in a yea proper company and
then I wouldn't make someone who sign up
for Kasia to go clean bathroom that's
why they have janitors and custodians
right yeah so that happened and I kind
of got like pissed at that you know it's
hard for me and then people people who
know me it's hard for me to get me get
me angry something I've never seen you
angry no matter if you when you get
scammed and [ __ ] over you don't get
angry ecstasy's in his blood he's
telling me stories of how he [ __ ] over
and he's smiling about it and I'm like
what's going on so so I was like alright
screw this and then you know at the town
selling on ebay so while I'm hustling I
was there I would they would put me to
work all the time was just cool I got
hours whatever you know and I wanted to
work towards manage and they start me
putting on the float they put me on the
floor - like rearrange stuff and then at
that time they they were selling
previously viewed DVDs and those are
like let's say Lord of the Ring Twin
Towers those they go up 425 at that time
that's what DVDs went for they did
something for like 6 bucks yeah so you
know I started to think I had a friend
that made DVD cases and then and I was
selling on half I was like oh [ __ ] maybe
I can sell DVDs and then I'd take I'd
buy all the stock they had at that time
they had there's a few movies mainly it
was a Lord of the Rings that I bought
and I bought like hundreds of them yeah
I had packaged them I bought a heat
sealer on eBay I'd repackage them brand
new and boom put them on and a half
common Amazon for brand new and I would
sell i sold all of my twenty five thirty
bucks
Wow there was a big drought of Lord of
the Rings at that time which I'd like it
was like that it's too much like if
you're slinging Ian yeah when it was
five bucks now it's out yourself a $40
you know and I took that philosophy so I
give credit to you know at that times
where people consider like a raving
drugs are bad but those are all life
experience that I took with me right
means I do right so from the first stage
of raving and all and then going into to
this business world yeah and then
applying that to my e-commerce and then
yeah and then the next thing I knew like
six months into my job the regional
manager they're like oh hey
they want to meet you tomorrow's our
cool probably promotion you know if I
become manager yeah and then we went to
them into the room and she was like what
are all these transactions I was like oh
just part of her families and friends
and next day I just I called the
managers like hey I'm out and didn't
show up and then Wow yeah all right [ __ ]
what I do I put another job
I do like Petco why did you decide to
quit did you feel weird about yeah it
was awkward after that because then
people were like dude this guy's doing
something crazy Shane yeah yeah what I
mean I bought and straight out though I
wasn't like taking these dollar DVDs I
was just like buying them but else yeah
yeah I could do it over all of them
right that's true but it was the same
title though yeah yeah it's cooler not
like [ __ ] what else can I sell what does
a I do and I try to apply to other like
jaws Petco and like everywhere yeah um I
think like ah SH Home Depot and I didn't
get a job like whatever's good this so I
started to like expand my online thing
and that you know I'm still playing
Street Fighter whatever so I went online
bought a ps2 controller and this is like
that controller is like I think what
launched my business career and there's
a $5 blue transparent blue piece yeah
you know looks like a Sony controller
they call him in China one to one epe
but 100% like the Sony no sony logo I
was cool it's like official and I play
is like oh this is junk you know so yeah
went back online sold it for 20 bucks I
was like I was put at 20 sell for 20 she
sold it for more yeah so for it was five
sold for 20 bucks well I remember the
sellers name was cat from Mars and then
here's from Florida there's a bunch of
Asian guys like I think from Hong Kong
or China and they lived in Florida and
they were doing trading whatever and I
didn't know I don't know anything about
wholesale or anything with that yeah so
I went to him and he had he he had a
bunch of packages like like three
controllers and a multi-tap you guys
remember yeah plug for controls yeah
that 20 bucks so three controllers and
that for 20 bucks free shipping I was
like Dan what a deal so I bought that
and then I was like damn this is junk
went back online 20 bucks each I
separated it so basically 2000's been I
mean I sold for 80 bucks okay $60 profit
I was like [ __ ] went back whatever money
I had from Blockbuster was like 568
bucks
700 something exactly and in boom you
just resell the product you were selling
on eBay
yeah I noticed
doing a lot of research what he'd be
like so I realized every seller had like
four or five six seven accounts and I
went to all the accounts about all those
inventory resold everything started
competing with them alright cool so
you're competing by buying their own
products and they're selling it for a
higher price
yeah how the [ __ ] did you do that but it
worked you know oh yeah which is crazy
so people could have got the same
controller for any price anybody could
could do that but at that time eBay and
I think Joey you've had experience at
eBay like at that time 2004 to 2007 8 it
was a like I think that was a B's prime
time where it was you've you had
anything for lower cost you can i still
make money from Alibaba or whatever now
it's like you make pennies right yeah
yeah at that time man I was making like
60 80 percent margins exactly yeah back
then I was like damn dude what else can
I sell what else yeah that's how like
people like got into the crazy
manufacturing because of those Ebates
uh-huh like like you know evike the yeah
yeah they remember I had a airsoft
company back there too and they remember
my [ __ ] and then yeah I got to be still
around
no they're they're around do they occupy
no no evike evike not ebike oh yeah yeah
and they're airsoft company but yet
they're old-school eBay to a lot of
these companies yeah old-school you baby
I don't have like crazy warehouses yeah
you know and it came from eBay so
anyways yeah and and and so I started
like I opened up some other accounts and
then just like expanding my inventory so
whatever those guys carried ps2
extension cables dance pads and then
dance pad is where I really like
expanded my company that's as revolution
yeah so we expand everything and then I
was like [ __ ] I need to like lower my
prices to get more mark like you know
increasing the profit margins so I was
googling different wholesalers in San
Gabriel Valley or SoCal la there's a
bunch of walnut in City Industry
contacted them set up accounts and then
started buying a bunch from them and I
stopped buying from the only sells
because I realized that I'm getting
ripped off even though I'm making so
much money then I realize I'm getting
like and then
- of a 50% even less now for the local
sellers and I'm like cleaning them out
yeah I have like three four different
accounts different names because it was
a good strategy cuz when people were
like let's say you go to Amazon you
don't buy from how example you go to
Target right it was that same concept
like I was like I had my Amazon my
target cetera but it's still going to
the same bank accounts yeah company with
different yes a different platform yeah
yeah you know see that's genius I never
did that yeah if you know that on Amazon
with electronics like oh yeah they do
yeah and they [ __ ] get my ass every
time yeah so it's all different brands
with the same company it's so funny
because there was this there was a
specific charger that I liked like a
portable charger they had a wall plug in
but it had six different courts attached
to it and it just suddenly just
disappeared what on the stock and then I
saw another I popped the begin but a
different company name I was like oh
that's the same but I'm still by it I
just bought it twice over dude it's
smart yeah yeah yeah but that's how they
get you
yeah so had a bunch of accounts and then
after the wholesalers I was like [ __ ] I
got to continue to cut the cost so I
went to Alibaba one day and then I just
like googled all this stuff that was
selling like crazy and our number one
item actually ended up being DDR Dan
spent like foam ones thin ones metal
dance pads that were sold at Fry's
Electronics and so what happened was I
found this guy I did a lot of a lot of
digging he's still in the gaming
business but just some random guy that
was on Alibaba and he was like oh I make
them and here's the price like damn is
it really the price was like 30 bucks
and I'd sell dance pads for 200 the
metal wow yeah and then and because we
would buy pallets of them and and then
what what happened was we ended up just
sending this got all this money and then
from the first year I went from that for
five six seven hundred to like two three
million dollars just shipping thousands
of packages a day by myself me my
brother has [ __ ] yeah I wake up in
the morning I have 30,000 my PayPal
account every day hallelujah this time
this was I was 20 21 oh my god dude yeah
just [ __ ] I didn't know what to do
man yeah and my brother you know he went
to business school whatever and I don't
know him brother and I was like alright
cool you come and help me like this
part-time and then he ended up quitting
his like corporate jobs or whatever yeah
what a - yeah and he was just helping me
because I didn't know what to do with
finance stuff I was getting a bunch of
money to know what to do right and then
I was like [ __ ] it just felt casual so I
was like oh [ __ ] I want to now have ten
I have twenty over fifty thousand
hundred thousand and I was like how do i
do you know it's crazy cuz what I you
know you inspired me to do eBay cuz we
would hear a rumor about you and be like
you know you know Joey made it right and
we're like what yeah I heard he made
like a hundred thousand dollars last
year and were like what and then I hear
no joy made a million dollars last year
and they're like what you're like nah
nah not joy made only seven hundred
thousand and then like people were
saying like our mutual friends you know
and then like I hear again joy he's a
millionaire joy made two million to
enjoy this I'm like I don't know I
haven't seen joy in a while but I'm like
thinking well I know Joey and we did
drugs he didn't do [ __ ] but it was also
something like I was always interested
in anything man yeah just know that
someone I knew [ __ ] made it on eBay
gave me the courage to just [ __ ] try
it dude yeah and you did it not at your
level bro but that was my first step
into business - yeah similar story but
yeah that's [ __ ] awesome
well how did you get into the gaming
thing then like what your what you have
now cuz you said yeah it's a it's good
it'll transition into like manufacturing
so so basically you know we started
selling a lot and and then buying Wiest
we'd send money to this guy on Alibaba
and then he ended up sending us metal
dance pads and I started I took a step
back from ecommerce I trained all my
friends to sell on eBay and then they
all became somewhat successful on eBay -
and and ran their own stores then we
started wholesaling to retailers like
Fry's Electronics what and then yeah so
we supplied like all those retailers
with these metal dance pads and stuff
you ever with the fries and - yeah yeah
we sold all those what the [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah that started from even you
know and then eBay at that time also
they're like damn because I all my
accounts for power seller accounts right
and you've if you guys know what Power
Cell is like you need maintain a good
feedback you know etc and then
they actually invited me to like eBay
like office to like common coach and
consult but I'd like denied doing that
because I just want to continue my
business and then my brother and I after
the first year we had our first
warehouse in Monrovia that was like
2,000 square feet we'd always like to
max it out we got our first container
after sending that guy that money blind
I was like kinda like a Hail Mary
you know I sent home money if I get this
stuff boom you know we're gonna make it
right like we're gonna double our
profits or triple or quadruple and then
he kept sending us W we said that we set
up a relationship and then 2006 at e3
expo if you guys know what that is yeah
we had our first trade show at that time
I imported these uh game projectors that
play ps2 or GameCube Xbox on the wall it
projects uh your your your game console
80 inches on the wall Wow yeah and I
told people I was the inventor of that
[Applause]
imported everything they had at that
time iPod was like becoming super hot oh
yeah and then like but you were the only
importer of it so then you didn't you
know someone else wasn't gonna be like
nah man
yeah well somebody came so so this is
the this is when I like really blew up
like in my entrepreneurs the guy that
actually invented it which he helped
Nintendo bring Super Mario to the global
market I won't say his name but he's
famous he's a Taiwanese guy he passed by
my booth with it with our other partner
who's a government official noun in
China that we pardoned with he walked by
hey where'd you get that I was like oh
the projector is that yeah oh it's my
product I invented it you want to buy
it's like he's like here's my card
this is my product I made this product
whoa
yeah and then and then he's like if you
come to China give me a call I love how
he wasn't offended that's like no
Chinese crazy like humble like Taichi
Taiwanese dude very very famous guy that
in reading industry people everybody
knows it's not that's amazing yeah it
was you know guy I stole it - yeah you
know get mad at
yes but all-star sure I was actually
buying from his our China partner his
one of his best friends that was selling
yeah so that's how they're all linked up
those guys in sell they're like big
shots you know so anyways I never went
to China ended up booking a flight me
and my brother we took one of my
brother's friends a Indian guy and then
another Shanghainese guy with us and
then we claimed to like they were our
like staff you know yeah
we were just like fronting figure yeah
make that kind of thing you know
oh my god we're going to China visiting
all of our venison jerky
he is our manager we're okay he's
perfect English like Joey I don't have
Indian accent do you they thought so
they actually that one night when we had
oh okay so we went to China did they all
speak English
like how did this go down yeah don't
speak any English at all except for like
hello so did you have to have a
translator there or did you have to
learn
so the Taiwanese guide which was my
mentor he